الزفاف الملكي في بروناي افتتاح كاس اسيا
في قطر وابنه تامر حسني تخطف الاضواء في
دبي المنافسه السينمائيه تحتدم في مصر
والحريفه ينافس بقوه اليكم الابرز في
[موسيقى]
اسبوع حظي زفاف الامير عبد المتين الابن
العاشر لسلطان بروناي باهتمام واسع على
منصات التواصل حول العالم وتعكس الصور
المتداوله من مراسم الزفاف الممتده لعشره
ايام الفخامه والبها في البلد الاسيوي
الذي يتمتع بثروه ضخمه وكان من ابرز مراسم
الاحتفال الجوله التي قام بها العروسان في
شوارع السلطنه وسبق للامير عبد المتين ان
شارك والده في مناسبات ملكيه عالميه منها
حفل زفاف الامير الحسين بن عبد الله
الثاني العام
الماضي ونبقى في القاره الصفراء والعرض
الفني الملفت لافتتاح النسخه الثامنه عشر
من بطوله كاس اسيا لكره القدم والذي حقق
تفاعلا على منصات التواصل العرض كان
بعنوان الفصل المفقود من كليله ودمنه
وافتتحت الفنانه اللبنانيه عبير نعمه
باغنيه وما ادراك ما قصه الرمال التي
اعادت مشاركتها عبر حساباتها الرسميه على
منصات التواصل وعبر تعبير عن سعادتها
بالمشاركه في هذا الحدث الذي قالت انه
سيبقى بصمه في مسيرتها وذاكرتها من
الرمال نحن ول الرمال كنا وكانت قبلنا
اجيا ومن اللحظات التي شاركتها عبير نعمه
من استاد لوسيل في الدوحه الى لحظات دافئه
تشاركها تامر حسني مع ابنته تاليا في
رحلته مؤخرا الى الامارات لاحياء حفل في
مهرجان دبي تاليا صعدت الى جانب تامر على
المسرح وشاركته في الحفل كدي جي في لقطات
حققت تفاعلا كبيرا من محبي النجم المصري
على منصات
التواصل ومن الصور التي حظيت بتفاعل واسع
الاسبوع الماضي اطلاله النجمه التركيه
مريم اوزيرلي المستوحاه من المسلسل
الكرتوني الشهير ماشا والدب احتفالا بعيد
ميلاد ابنتها الثالث كما حققت صور الاعلان
عن ارتباط الفنانين المصريين هشام جمال
وليلى احمد زاهر بتفاعل كبير على منصات
التواصل في
مصر اخيرا وفي مصر ايضا تحتدم المنافسه
بين ثلاثه افلام سينما
على صداره ايرادات شباك التذاكر لفتره
موسم راس السنه واجازه منتصف العام
الدراسي حيث تفيد تقارير بتصدر فيلم
الحريفه القائمه مؤخرا بعد ان تجاوزت
ايرادات فيلم الاسكندراني الذي سبق واحتل
الصداره منتصف الاسبوع الماضي على حساب
فيلم ابو نسب لكن الارقام تشهد تغيرات
متسارعه بانتظار طرح المزيد من الافلام
خلال الموسم الحالي شهر عسل
ماتنسيش l